ก็
สวัสดีค่ะทุเรียนงหวัดดีค่ะคุณผู้หญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนคู่เรียมวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพตอะไรคะผช
[เพลง]
2565 ค่ะค่ะปีคศอะไรคะคอสต์
2022 ค่ะ
ค่ะแล้วแต่ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้ 8:00
น 59 นาทีค่ะครูหญิง
อีก 1 นาทีก็ 9:00 นใช่แล้ว
หรอ
08:00 นยังไงบ้างคะผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมคะ
สบายดีค่ะครูเรียมล่ะคะสบายดีนะคะเตรียม
ก็สบายดีค่ะอิอิ
ก็ผู้หญิงก็เหมือนดูทีวีไม่ได้ดูทีวีน้อง
เหมือนที่เห็นนะคะว่า
เหมือนตอนนี้เนี่ยคนไทยมีเวลาแล้วก็ไป
เที่ยวมากๆสวยเหมือนว่า
ทุกอย่างเดี๋ยวมันโอเคแล้วชายคนไทยก็คิด
อยากจะไปเที่ยว
the  three  realms เนี่ยเป็นคนชอบ
เที่ยงตกไว้สารเตรียมชอบเที่ยวมากๆค่ะผู้
หญิง
คนไทยก็ลืมโควิชไปแล้ว
ก็เลยไปออกจะต้องไปเที่ยวกันเยอะมากๆ
ดีเลยค่ะพ่อครูเรียนชอบเที่ยววันนี้เนี่ย
ครูหญิงจะมีคำถามเกี่ยวกับการไปเที่ยว
[เพลง]
มากนะไม่ยากนักกูเรียมมีให้ครูเรียมเนี่ย
เลือดแค่ 1 กับ 2 หรือว่า a กับ B ให้ครู
เตรียมเรียกว่าถ้าเวลาครูเรียมไปเที่ยว
ชอบแบบไหนระหว่างเอหรืออีก
ป๋อง
ฮะโอเคค่ะครูเรียมอันแรกนะคะครูเรียม
เนี่ยชอบถ้าไปเที่ยวนะถ้าไปที่รักชอบ
เที่ยวแบบไหนระหว่างแบบที่ 1 เที่ยวใน
เมืองในเมืองมีตึก
มีรถน้องมีถนนนะคะเที่ยวในเมืองหรือว่า
ว่า 2 เที่ยวธรรมชาติมีแม่น้ำมีต้นไม้ถ้า
เวลาเวลาครูเรียมไปเที่ยวเรียนชอบเที่ยว
แบบไหนคะเที่ยวในเมืองหรือว่าเที่ยว
ธรรมชาติ
เลี่ยมชอบเที่ยวแบบที่ 2 ค่ะ
เที่ยวธรรมชาติ
ทุเรียนชอบแบบธรรมชาติใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะแล้ว
เรียบถามครูขอได้ไหมคะผู้หญิงชอบเที่ยว
แบบไหน
ผู้หญิงอ่ะเลือกจากหรอ
แต่ว่าถ้าให้หลักผู้หญิงชอบเที่ยวในเมือง
เหรอชอบเที่ยวในเมืองเพราะว่าคิดว่าวัน
นี้มีร้านอาหารมีอะไรให้ดูช้อปปิ้งเกิด
เที่ยวในเมืองและกันเหมือนคู่เดียวนะ
เดี๋ยวชอบดูต้นไม้
ดูหนังเอา
God  Is  2 ใช่ไหมคะเวลาที่เราไปเที่ยว
เนี่ยเราก็ต้องนอนสมัยต้องรอแต่ว่าเราไป
เที่ยวเราก็ไม่มีบ้านไม่มีอพาร์ทเม้นท์นะ
คะเวลาครูเรียมไปเที่ยวเนี่ยเราต้องจอง
ก่อนเนาะจองก่อนที่เราจะไปเที่ยวนะคะครู
เรียมชอบนอนที่พักแบบไหนอ่ะ
111 นอนโรงแรมในโรงแรมเนี่ยก็อาจจะมีดาว
นั้นหน้ามีดาวนอนโรงแรม 5 ดาวเลยละกันนะ
คะหรือว่า 2
พรรคอะไรนะแอล bnb มันจะคล้ายๆเป็นบ้าน
ใช่ไหมเป็นได้
ถึงบ้านแล้วก็ให้เราเราไปแบ่งนอนได้คู่
เรียนชอบทักแบบไหนครับพักที่โรงแรมหรือ
ว่าแอร์บีเอ็นบี
เตรียมชอบพักที่โรงแรมค่ะ
กูยังชอบโรงแรมใช่ไหมคะทำไม
กำไมชอบโรงแรมมันก็สบาย
สบายๆแล้วก็
รู้สึกว่าอ่ะ
ถ้าไม่อยู่สิแบบไม่ต้องไปคุยกับคนอื่น
อยู่คนเดียวนี้ฉัน
จบ
แล้วก็หญิงนะคะสวาทชอบพักที่โรงแรมหรือ
ว่า
abnb
อาข้อนี้ Green เหมือนครูเรียมนะคะผู้
หญิงชอบพักที่โรงแรมเหมือนกันเพราะว่าคิด
ว่าไม่ต้องแบ่งคล่องข้อถือตัวห้องน้ำกับ
ใครที่ว่าถ้าแอร์บีเอ็นบีไม่แน่ใจว่าห้อง
น้ำที่อาบนา
[เพลง]
ก็เพราะว่าครูเรียนในชอบธรรมชาติไงเที่ยว
ธรรมชาติก็เลยต้องการเต้นท์รถผู้หญิงไม่
ชอบการเต็มนะคะก็เลยไม่มีให้เลือกไม่ได้
เรื่อยๆแค่ 1  1 กับ 2 โอเคโอเค
ข้อต่อไปนะคะเวลาครูเรียมไปเที่ยวใช่ไหม
บางครั้งเนี่ยมันก็ต้องเดินทางไม่ใช่เดิน
ทางไปเที่ยวจะเดินทางไปเที่ยวก็ได้เนาะ
ถ้าเราอยู่อย่างผู้หญิงอยู่กรุงเทพแล้ว
อยากจะไปเชียงใหม่หรือว่าครูเรียมอยู่ที่
บ้านแล้วอยากจะมากรุงเทพฯนะหรือไปเที่ยว
ที่ไหนอย่างนี้ค่ะครูเรียมชอบเดินทางแบบ
ไหนอ่ะแบบเดินทางโดยเครื่องบินหรือว่ารถ
ไฟ
[เพลง]
ถ้าไปเที่ยวเรียมชอบเดินทาง
ด้วยรถไฟ
ทำไมอ่ะ
อารุไฟนานนะกูเลี้ยงใช่ค่ะนานมากแต่ว่า
เล่นชอบดูดูกับค่าอันนี้เป็นทางรถไฟใช่
ไหมที่เราเห็นแล้วข้างทางก็จะมีต้นไม้ไง
ก็คือเปิดดูวิวใช่มั้ยแล้วห้องน้ำรถไฟ
บ่ายวันนี้พี่อยู่ก็คือนั่งเครื่องบินมัน
ไม่มีวิวนะมันเห็นแต่ก้อนเมฆอ่ะค่ะเจ้ใช่
ค่ะแล้วมันไม่เห็นข้างล่างอ่ะเครื่องบิน
เห็นข้างบนเห็นข้างล่างนิดเดียว
หนึ่งก็เลยชอบเล่นก็เลยชอบรถไฟให้ค่ะผู้
หญิงรู้ไหมคะเรียงมีเพื่อนเพื่อนที่มาจาก
ค่ะอ่าประเทศนะเล่มก็พาเขาไปเที่ยวด้วยรถ
ไฟนี่แหละ
จะเตรียมคิดว่าเรียนเป็นคนที่ตื่นเต้นมาก
กว่าเพื่อนนั้นเฮ้ยยมีเวลานั่งในรถไฟ
[เพลง]
สวยๆแต่ลืมก็เลยหันไปมองแบบมองหน้าของ
เพื่อนเพื่อนก็เลย
อะไรจะเป็นอะไรอ่ะเป็นอะไรกูก็เลยคิดอัน
นี้เป็นคนใช่หรอคนไทยใช่ไหม
ยังไม่ชอบมากค่ะชอบมาก
ค่ะแล้วผู้หญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิงชอบเดินทาง
ด้วยเครื่องบินหรือรถไฟ
จริงๆฮ่าๆๆไหนประเทศนะคะผู้หญิงก็ชอบรถไฟ
มากกว่ารู้สึกเครื่องบินมันมันเร็วอะ
เอามันเร็วก็แล้วรถไฟ
ละกันนะคิดว่านะนานแต่ไม่มีตัวเรื่องที่ 3
พี่
บาสอาจจะดีกว่านะคะเข้าไปเที่ยวนะเลยคิด
ว่าโอเคแต่ถ้าเกิดไปเครื่องบินเครื่องบิน
ค่ะจะซุปใช้เวลาแป๊ปเดียวแต่เวลาไปเที่ยว
เราก็ดูดูข้างทางก็สบายๆ
ว่าเรามีเวลาเยอะไงคะเวลาเราไปเที่ยวเรา
แบบสบายๆเนาะครับก็ต่อไปนะคะเวลาโคเรียม
ไปเที่ยวถ้ามีให้เลือกอันนี้นะอ่าเราไป
เที่ยวใช่ไหมคะระหว่างอันแรกอันที่หนึ่ง
เนาะไปดูศิลปะสมัยเนี่ยศิลปะน้องเป็นรูป
ว่าใช่ไหมคะรูปวาดหรือว่าจะเป็นรูปถ่ายก็
ได้นะคะศิลปะหรือว่าแบบ 2 ไปดูอะไรที่
เป็น
เก่าๆอย่างเนี้ยเหมือนถ้าประเทศไทยก็จะไป
อยุธยา
อ่ะอยากเป็นตึกใช่ไหมดูสิน่าจะแบบ 5 ค่า
ร้อยปีหวย 500 ปีแล้วเก่าๆอ่ะปูเรียมจะ
เลือกอันไหนยากหรออย่า
2 อันได้ไหม
เรียงเลือก 2 อันได้ไหมต้องเรื่องดึงไม่
ได้ค่ะต้องเลือกหนึ่งว่าศิลปะหรือ
อะไรที่เก่า
ก็เลยอ่ะ
เลือกเรื่องอะไรล่ะคุณเลือกไม่ได้
ชอบทั้งสองอย่างเลย
แต่เลือกเลย
ค่ะ
ทำไมอ่ะ
ชอบ
ทำไมคะเพราะว่าอะไรก็เพราะตอนนี้ตอนนี้
รู้สึกร้อน
เตรียมเคยไปอยุธยาแล้วอ้ะมันร้อนมาก
เหมือนเก่า
เมืองเก่าแล้วก็ไปเดินๆ
ดีพระอาทิตย์แล้วมันร้อนมาก
เรียมเดินอยู่ที่นี่นะคะใช่
แต่ถ้าไปดูศิลปะเนี่ยไม่รอเนาะเพราะว่าใน
อยู่ไหนห้องแอร์ใช่ก็เลยคิดแบบนั้นแหละ
ค่ะคืออะไรอ่ะนั้นเลือกหนึ่งก็ได้จริงๆก็
ชอบทั้ง 2 อย่าง
ค่ะแล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะ
ผู้หญิง
หญิงหญิงเลือกไม่ยากเลยค่ะครูเรียมผู้
หญิงเลือก 2 ค่ะเลือกเมืองเก่าที่หญิงไม่
ชอบดูศิลปะรู้สึกไม่รู้มีอะไร
ทำไมเราไปเดินแล้วก็ดูหรอเราดูอะไรอ่ะไม่
เข้าใจไงก็เลยอันนี้เนี้ยแกอันนี้ไม่อ่าน
ใช่ไหมว่าโอ้เมืองนี้นานขนาดไหนก็รู้สึก
จะชอบเมืองเก่ามากว่าศิลปะ
จะๆมีเข้าไหมอะมีนะคะโอ้อันนี้เป็น
ธรรมชาติทั้งสองอย่างเลยทั้ง 2 ที่เลย
คือเรียกวอถ้าคู่เรียมไปเที่ยวทรุดมีเวลา
เลือกไปเที่ยวได้แค่ที่เดียวนะระหว่าง 1
เที่ยวทะเลกับ 2 เที่ยวภูเขาครูเรียม
เลือกอะไร
หุ้ย
ระหว่างทะเลกับภูเขา
เรื่องทะเล
มี
ทุเรียนเลือกคะเลยทำไมคะทำไมเลือกทะเล
เพราะว่าว่าไม่ได้ไปทะเลนานมากๆแล้ว
ฮอตเตรียมไปภูเขาน่ะเดือนที่แล้วไปภูเขา
สัปดาห์ที่แล้วไปภูเขาก็เลยภูเขาภูเขาภู
เขาเห็นภูเขาบ่อยมาก
ก็เลยเดี๋ยวบ่อยแล้วใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าก็ชอบก็
สั่งแล้วนะ
แล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะ
ให้คุณหญิงเลือด
ไปทะเลเองเรื่อง
คุยเลือกทะเลค่ะผู้หญิงไม่ค่อยชอบถูก
เอาเท่าไหร่แบบเดินใช่ไหมแล้วเราแบบต้อง
เดินเขาอ่ะแล้วก็กางเต็นท์แบบคุณเรียม
ป.ป.ช.เชียงใหม่แต่ผู้หญิงนั่นแหละมาไม่
ค่อยชอบพี่ก็เลยนะเลือกทะเลดีกว่าค่ะก็
เลยเลือกทะเล
ว้าวผู้ชาย
มีอีกนะแต่ไม่มีรูปให้ดูแล้วนะคะเวลาที่
ครูเรียมไปเที่ยวใช่ไหมไปเที่ยวแต่ละที่
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะครูเรียมเนี่ยอันแรกเนาะวาง
แผนไหมวางแผนเที่ยวแต่ว่าคิดไว้ว่าเฮ้ย
วันนี้ตื่นนอนมาเราจะไปที่ไหนไปที่ไหนกิน
อะไร
เดินทางยังไงอันนี้คือวางแผนทุกวันกู
เรียนก็จะมีเลยมีแผนมีแผนวันที่ 1 ดูอะไร
วันที่ 2 ดูอะไรอย่างนี้คือวางแผนเวลาไป
เที่ยวนะคะหรือสอบใหม่แล้วแต่แล้วแต่ว่า
เอ๋ตื่นนอนมาวันนี้มีอารมณ์แบบอย่างจะ
เดินจะไปเที่ยวก็ไปโพเรียมเป็นแบบไหน
ระหว่างเป็นคนที่วางแผนเที่ยวหรือไม่แล้ว
แต่อารมณ์เรื่องเป็นคนที่ไม่วางแผนเที่ยว
ค่ะแล้วแต่ว่าคือแล้วแต่อารมณ์ให้วันนี้
อากาศดีอากาศดีแดดออกไปเดินข้างนอกก็ไป
เดินทางนอก
วันนี้อากาศดีอยากขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์ไปข้าง
นอกก็ไปแต่ถ้าแบบแขดรอน่ะหลอดมากก็อยู่
ที่นี่ก่อนแล้วกันแต่ว่าไม่ได้แบบวางแผน
ว่าพรุ่งนี้จะทำอะไรพรุ่งนี้จะทำอะไรไม่
มีค่ะนอกจากจะไปกับเพื่อนเราเพื่อนก็จะ
บอก V ร้านอาหารร้านเนี้ยกินแล้วแบบอร่อย
มากถ้าเราเนี่ยต้องไปนะเดี๋ยวโอเคโอเค
ที่นี่แบบดีมาก
เราต้องไปที่นี่แบบเพื่อนเนี่ยเพื่อนบอก
ว่าโอเคโอเคไปแต่ถ้าไปคนเดียวน่ะไม่วาง
เเผ
อาจจะเลือกอื่นแล้วมาที่ 1 ว่าอยากไปช่วย
นะที่สุดแล้วก็นอกจากนั้นนี่ก็คือแบบสบาย
ๆ
ก็คือ
ไม่มีแฟนน่ะหรอก็คืออยากไปแค่ที่นี่เท่า
นั้นแล้วก็ที่เหลือก็แล้วแต่อารมณ์เลยใช่
ค่ะแล้วผู้หญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิงชอบวางแผนไหม
หรือว่าไม่วางแผน
ดีจริงก็เลือกแย่งนะไปเที่ยวเนาะบักเราก็
อยากไปดูอะไรที่แบบไปแล้วก็ต้องไปดูนะคะ
แต่ส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยพี่ก็ว่าไม่ค่อยวางแผน
มากกว่าพ่อมันคล้ายๆครูเรียมแหละบางครั้ง
เราตื่นมารู้สึกแบบเออเมื่อวานเราเชี่ยว
เยอะมากเลยอ่ะวันนี้เราเหนื่อยแล้วอ่ะก็
อาจจะแบบไม่ไปแล้วกันเนี่ยกับแล้วแต่
อารมณ์มากกว่าเป็นคนที่เที่ยวรอบแล้วแต่
อารมณ์
ร้องจะเหมือนกันเนาะถ้าเที่ยวกับเพื่อน
เราก็คงต้องมีการวางแผนสวยเพราะเราไม่ได้
ไปคนเดียวถ้าใช่ถ้าเกิดไปคนเดียวก็สบายๆ
เราเราก็คิดคนเดียวในไปกับเพื่อนเพื่อน
อยากไปที่ไหนเพื่อนอย่างเที่ยวที่ไหนเรา
ก็ลองพูดคุยกันคือ
จ่ายข้อต่อไปนะคะเวลาแบบนี้ผู้หญิงที่ว่า
คูเรียมน่าจะเลือกและเอ้อไม่ยากนะเวลาไป
เที่ยวสมัยไปเที่ยวเนี่ยเรียมชอบเขาเรียก
อะไรอ่ะคะชอบแบบไหนระหว่างหนึ่งก็คือ
ไปเที่ยวหรอก็ไปดูรถไปเชียงใหม่ไปภูเก็ต
อย่างนี้ก็ไปเดินแล้วก็ดูดูภูเขาดูวัด
เนี่ยไปเดินดูใช่ไหมคะหรือ 2 เวลาไป
เที่ยวเน้นอะไรละกันเดินวันเด่นอะไรเน้น 1
ไปเดินดูสวยดูดูๆหรือว่า 2 เน้น Shopping
เดินแล้วก็ shopping  shopping  shopping
shopping ซื้อของเยอะๆทุเรียนเป็นแบบไหน
เตรียมเป็นแบบที่ 1 ชอบไปเดินเร็วๆๆ
ฟูดูทุกอย่างไม่รู้ทำไมที่นี่ประเทศไทย
แล้วเรียนก็ไปเที่ยวในประเทศตัวเองแหละ
แล้วก็จะเป็นคนที่ตื่นเต้นกับทุกอย่างที่
เห็นแล้วอ่ะ
แต่
ถ้าเกิดคู่หญิงก็ไปกับครูเดียวนะผู้หญิง
ก็คิดว่าเดี๋ยวนะกูยังไม่เคยมาเหรอไม่เคย
ไม่เคยออกจากบ้านหรอ
ก็จะชอบดูค่ะแต่ไม่ค่อยซื้อนะครับซื้อเลย
ถึงไม่ได้เน้นว่าไปเที่ยวเราไปซื้อของใช่
ไหมคือบางคนเขาไปเที่ยวก็จะเน้นแบบ
Shopping ว่าเออไปซื้ออะไรดีมีอะไรขาย
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยแต่ผู้เรียมน่าจะเน้นแบบไป
เที่ยวเนาะไปเที่ยวแล้วก็ไปดูมาก่อนก็ไป
ถ่ายรูป
ชอบค่ะแบบนั้นตกถ้าเกิดเรียงเห็นบางอย่าง
ที่แบบทำให้เรียนแบบนึกถึงครูหญิงเรียนก็
อาจจะซื้อนะค่ะขึ้นอุ๊ยผู้หญิงต้องชอบแน่
เลยหนึ่งก็ซื้อไปให้ผู้หญิงดีกว่าแบบ
เนี้ยมีแต่ไม่ได้แบบไปหาว่าจะซื้ออะไร
ซื้ออะไรไม่ใช่
แล้วก็รู้อยู่ว่ากลับไปเที่ยวล่ะ
ผู้หญิงชอบจะสึกหรอ
ปิ้งนะแต่ถ้าเวลาไปเที่ยวจริงๆผู้หญิงก็
เน้นไปดูว่ากว่าไม่ไม่ได้คิดว่าแบบว่าโอ้
เมืองเอาไปเชียงใหม่ต้องไปช้อปปิ้งที่ไหน
เนี่ยอ่ะไม่สนใจขนาดไหนแค่บอกว่าอ๋อไป
แล้วก็ไปดูมีอะไรจะไม่ได้ตื่นเต้นเท่าคุณ
เรียมนะ
จะได้ตื่นเต้นแต่ทำให้เคยเห็นไม่เคยไปว่า
จะตื่นเต้นนะคะ
ฟิล์มก็เลยอยากรู้เลยเวลาเวลาเวลาที่ผู้
หญิงไปเที่ยวนะผู้หญิงเป็นยังไงก็ผู้หญิง
อ่ะอย่างนี้หรือเปล่าหรือว่า
ใช่ผู้หญิงก็ตื่นเต้นนะถ้ามันแบบว่ามัน
น่ารักจะเออคือเป็นคนชอบเที่ยวเมืองมันบ่
ขอแรงชื่อหมายที่บอกไปแล้วชอบเที่ยวใน
เมืองแต่ไม่ชอบแบบถ้าพูดถึงกรุงเทพฯไม่
ชอบแบบสยามสแควร์อะไรเงี้ยถ้าเราไปเที่ยว
นะอ่ะชอบแบบมีความเป็นเมืองเดินทางง่ายๆ
แบบมีอะไรเดินเหนื่อยก็มีร้านให้นั่งเลย
เนี่ยชอบแบบเมืองจะเป็นเมืองเล็กๆอะไร
อย่างนี้อ่ะค่ะก็เลยหรอกโต๊ะแต่ว่าจะไม่
ได้แบบว้าวอะไรก็จะสวยก็หยิบโทรศัพท์ขึ้น
มาแล้วก็ถ่ายรูปแค่นั้น
อ๋อ
แม่เขาวันนี้ก็เลยมาเล่น
เกมเกมเป็นหยังเนาะสนุกๆนะคะถามครูเรียม
ว่าครูเรียมชอบเที่ยวแบบไหนไม่มี a กับ D
B ให้เลือกนะคะบ้ายเลียมก็เลยรู้ไปด้วย
เลยว่าผู้หญิงชอบเที่ยวแบบไหน
ไก่ค่ะเนาะโรงเรียนเมชอบแบบไหนเลือก
เหมือนเรามั้ยอ่าแต่มี 2 ตัวเลือกใช่ไหม
คะให้เลือกใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้ว
ค่ะผู้หญิง
ผิดหน้าแล้วแหละ
สายค่ะก็สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
วิ่งไปเที่ยวใช่ไหมครับอ่า